as above so below is a new found footage
horror film and I know the majority of
you just went I don't give a crap I'm
done with these things I'm done they're
just movies that are really cheap they
cost like two dollars if they make ten
dollars the box office we have ourselves
a profit a young girl who's incredibly
smart she's an explorer
she has like a billion degrees she knows
a billion different languages including
dead ones and she just taking a whole
bunch of people that we know will more
than likely die because we don't give a
crap about any of them
down into the catacombs of Paris because
she is looking for the Philosopher's
Stone that's right the Philosopher's
Stone that's what she wants to look for
she really wants that thing man
her father went nuts and killed himself
searching for it so she does have an
emotional attachment to it and now we're
down there and things are happening
there's all these inscriptions and they
seem to hint that they're going
someplace metaphorically but they're
actually there and some serious stuff
starts going on I gotta be honest this
movie started out so incredibly awful
that I was like this is the worst movie
of the year I would say this movie has
one of the worst setups of this entire
year like this really strange thing
happens at the beginning that's never
really explained it doesn't really seem
to have much connection to the story
either and then she just goes around
picks up some random people and almost
as like they're just like improving the
entire script they're like here's this
yeah thing and there's a catacomb and
we're gonna go there but I will be
completely honest I would say the last
20 minutes of this movie actually did
scare me a little bit and I have to be
honest about that I got to give the
filmmakers credit there was some
legitimate scary imagery that did
creeped me out and there was some good
use of sound despite the fact there's
overuse of the jump scare element which
is so incredibly annoying because there
isn't actually any real tension to that
you're just anticipating a loud and
hoyes that will eventually occur and so
you're just waiting for this boom when
there really isn't actually some tension
in the air because you don't give a crap
about any's characters because the story
isn't interesting when did horror films
stop giving us cool stories and just
become obsessed with loud sound effects
also get to film this the actors aren't
doing a bad job performance
in this movie are not terrible also the
film has what I call the excuse where
you put your characters in a place you
say this is where they are maybe and if
they're there we can just do anything we
want and if someone says what was that
can you explain that all you have to do
is say the excuse whatever your excuse
is this is where they are and now
anything can happen we can show this if
someone goes what the heck just happened
you just say your excuse of where they
are and everything is okay the director
of this movie directed the Pope hypsi
tapes devil and the American remake of
wreck quarantine wreck was a fantastic
French found footage film quarantine was
literally just a copy of it so he has
had experience with found footage films
but I don't really feel like there's
anything here that's too different from
all the rest it's just sound effects and
some creepy stuff that happens in the
last 10 to 15 minutes of this movie and
I was like okay that was some legitimate
scary stuff but up until then I was
incredibly bored it was just a whole
bunch of sound effects there's even a
part where the ceiling is cracking above
them and a guy looks up and goes that's
not good is it that's that's bad right
that's I'm like yeah that's pretty bad
you might die why are you asking if it's
bad the ceilings about the collapse on
you and kill you I'm gonna give it as
above so below a d-plus it has some good
performances it does have some creepy
moments but for the most part it's a
found footage film with a whole bunch of
jump scares and I couldn't really get
into it guys what are your thoughts on
this film if you have seen it what's
your favorite found footage film there
are a lot of different kinds I'm curious
to know what your favorite is as always
guys thank you so much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck nice
you